- Welcome to the Lifespan podcast,
where we discuss the science of aging
and how to be healthier
at any stage of life.
I'm David Sinclair.
I'm a professor of genetics
at Harvard Medical School,
and I'm also co-director
of the Paul F. Glenn Center
for Biology of Aging Research.
In this podcast series,
we're talking about why we age
and how to slow, stop and
even reverse that process,
to give us longer and healthier lives.
In this final episode of
the eight part series,
we're talking about the very near future,
what's coming down the line
that will potentially
greatly extend our lifespans.
I'm joined here by my lovely co-host
and my co-author of "Lifespan",
Matthew LaPlante, welcome.
- Hey, thank you.
- So yeah, we've been talking
over the last few minutes
about what the future really looks like
and how much it's going
to change our lives,
but even how hard it is
to predict the future
just a few years out,
'cause things are changing so quickly.
- Well, in fact, we set off
to give some predictions
when we worked on "Lifespan" together.
And a lot of the things that you had said,
you envisioned coming down
the line maybe five years out,
maybe 10 years out.
By the time the book had published,
and certainly now two years
after the book had published,
they're already here.
- We even have this
illustration in the book
of a person going online,
doing a telemedicine
interview with a doctor
and having medicines
delivered to their home,
in that case, by drones.
But we're pretty much already
there, thanks to the pandemic.
- Yeah we are and I think
there's a lot of other things
that are just coming a lot faster
than we could have even envisioned.
And also in part, because of the pandemic,
because the pandemic
has really brought so
many of us face to face
with some of the constraints
of how our world was organized
in the before times and how
that it's not very flexible,
it's not very responsive to the needs
that we are experiencing,
not just in the pandemic,
but also as we reorchestrate
our lives in the 21st century.
- Yeah, and even when we wrote the book,
there was pushback even
within our conversations,
how realistic is it that people
will take their own healthcare,
medical care into their own hands
and would they be allowed to?
And we've been rapidly
pushed into to that world,
where you can take home tests
for pretty much anything.
You can have blood tests
Of course, doctors have to be involved,
but you don't have to go see a doctor-
- You don't have to go
to a doctor's office.
- Right, and in the future,
it's going to be rarer
to go to see your doctor.
Most of it's going to be done remotely
and you won't even know the doctor
that's involved in prescribing something.
- And thank God, really,
because there's really no
experience people like less
than going to the doctor.
- Well-
- If you can do that in
the comfort of your home,
it's going to be a better experience.
- Well, yeah, I was pretty
sure I would get sicker
when I went to that waiting room
with people coughing
and sneezing everywhere.
Hospitals are just as
bad, it's pretty risky,
particularly as an older
person, going to the hospital.
And if you don't need to, if
you can be monitored at home,
which is increasingly possible,
then a lot of people won't
die from an infection
that they would typically
get at the hospital.
- You said monitoring,
and I think this is a overarching theme
of this podcast series so far.
One of the things we've
said again and again,
is that you can't impact
what you don't measure.
And so today, we're going to
talk a lot about wearables
and implantables,
and we're going to talk
about how these innovations,
along with scaled access
to biological aging clocks
is going to change the
way we address health.
- Yeah, and before we get to that,
this podcast is made available freely.
And the reason is we have sponsors
that help us monitor our bodies
and keep the nutrition
at the right levels,
based on that feedback.
Our first sponsor is Levels.
Levels is an app that syncs
with a continuous glucose
monitor, which they provide,
and interprets your glucose data for you.
I've been so impressed using Levels,
that I recently joined the
company as a scientific advisor.
By monitoring your blood glucose,
Levels allows you to see how
different foods affect you.
I've had fun running tests of my own,
seeing how different foods
impact my blood sugar levels.
For example, I've learned that white rice
really spikes my blood sugar,
whereas potatoes don't.
As we've discussed on this podcast,
having stable blood
glucose is very important,
not only for daily mental
and physical energy,
but also for long-term health.
So if you'd like to try Levels,
you can skip the 150,000 person wait list
and go there straight
to the top of the line
and join today by going
to levels.link/sinclair.
That's levels.link/sinclair.
Today's episode is also brought
to us by Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens is an all
in one daily greens drink,
that supports better health
and peak performance.
It's developed from a
complex blend of 75 vitamins,
minerals and whole food
sourced ingredients.
It's filled with adaptogens for recovery,
probiotics, prebiotics,
and digestive enzymes for gut health,
along with vitamin C and zinc
citrate for immune support.
I've been drinking Athletic
Greens each morning
for a number of years now,
as a way to cover all
my nutritional bases.
I'm often traveling, sometimes
my diet isn't the best,
and as what happened today, we ran out,
and it was really painful
not having a start of the day
with Athletic Greens.
So if you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair
and claim a special offer.
They're giving five free travel packs,
plus a year supply of vitamin
D three for immune support
and vitamin K two,
which keeps the calcium
out of your arteries
and keeps it in your
bones where it belongs.
Again, go to athleticgreens.com/sinclair,
my last name,
to claim the this special offer.
Today's podcast is also
brought to us by InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from
your blood and your DNA
to help you better understand your body
and reach your health goals.
I've been using InsideTracker
for over a decade
and I'm the chair of their
scientific advisory board.
The reason I've long used InsideTracker,
is because they provide the
best blood and DNA analysis
that I'm aware of.
They make it easy to get your blood drawn,
you can either go to a nearby clinic
or, like I do, have
someone come to your home,
it's really convenient.
From there, InsideTracker
analyzes your data
and presents that data in
an easy to understand way.
Another feature that InsideTracker offers
is their inner age test,
which I helped develop.
This test shows you what
your biological age is,
and how it compares to
your chronological age
and what you can do to
improve that number.
So if you'd like to try InsideTracker,
you can visit them at
insidetracker.com/sinclair,
and then you'll get a 25%
discount off any of their plans,
Use the code Sinclair, my
last name, at the checkout.
- Okay, so David, let's get into this.
And to do this, to talk about the future,
we have to talk a little
bit about the past,
we have to talk about the
world we're in right now
when it comes to healthcare.
Right now, our healthcare
system is based on a model
that has developed over
the last few hundred years.
And that model basically amounts
to wait till you get sick,
then go see your doctor.
And when you and I have
talked about this before,
you said that actually
makes plenty of sense
in the context of the
19th and 20th centuries.
- Well, it does, because
doctors had no way of knowing
if you were sick,
other than asking you how you feel,
and they couldn't do that remotely,
certainly not through video,
but they also needed to feel you
and to take samples in the office.
Right now, you can wear a biosensor,
a monitor or do a blood test
from home or a local clinic,
that will give the doctor
way more information
than they could ever get
by seeing you in person.
So a case in point, I saw my
doctor maybe six months ago
and I hadn't seen him for a year
and it was a video conference,
and it was supposed to be
very quick, 10 minutes.
He said, "David, how do you feel?"
"I'm feeling good."
"How are you sleeping?"
"Not so good."
"Well, you should get more sleep,
"try to not do your emails too late.
"Anything else you want to talk about?"
And I said, "Yeah, there's a lot.
"I'm, you know, 52, I
could have colon cancer,
"I could have all these other issues.
"Let's do some tests."
And he says, "Well, okay, what
kind of tests do you want?"
So I said, "What about
a prostate cancer test?
"You know, for my age, I
could have prostate cancer.
"My neighbor just died
from prostate cancer."
And he said, "Well, do you
have a family history?"
"Not that I know of."
"Do you feel sick?"
"No."
He goes, "Well, then there's
no need to do the test."
I said, "Hold it right
there, hold it right there.
"Are you telling me
"that I need to have a
large tumor in my prostate
"that's causing me to be sick,
before I come and see you?"
And he said, "Yeah."
- Yes, right.
- Yes.
That's craziness.
- And that's model
of medicine in the 20th century, right?
- And then, it's often too late,
then I'm on my way to death.
So these days, there are
tests that you can do
that your doctor can order.
There's a new one that's
just about to be released
by a company called GRAIL
and there are many others,
that, with a finger prick
or a little blood test
from a local clinic,
you can detect 50
different types of cancers
before they even become tumors
and kill them years
before they would show up
and have you go to a doctor,
which is often too late.
- Let's talk about why that is,
because when a cancer cell starts to form,
when a tumor starts to form,
it begins releasing
into the bloodstream these
signalers, blood analytes.
And if we can detect those,
we can detect cancer at the
very, very earliest stages.
- Well, that's right,
and they give off a lot
of different signals.
Out of the breath and in the bloodstream,
they leach proteins, they leach DNA, RNA,
and even the types of DNA that come out,
those little fragments,
they have little ends,
it's not the whole
chromosome that comes out,
they get chopped up, the cancer cells die,
and out come these little pieces.
Those pieces have chemicals
on them, the DNA methylation,
the clock that can be read,
and even at the ends,
how they were cut up
by enzymes in the cell,
can tell you, indeed,
that is a stage one liver cancer,
even though we picked it
up in the bloodstream.
- Which means we don't now need to wait
for a tumor to grow, to metastasize,
for it to spread into
other systems in the body.
There is increasingly a chance
of catching these kinds
of problems earlier.
And it's not just cancer,
it's a lot of diseases, heart disease,
which is not a cancer, right?
Also, there are signs of heart disease
that you can pick up through
these early warning signals.
- Exactly, so with the cancer,
we've been slowly reducing
the incidence of cancer
and particularly the
ability to survive cancer
and we haven't cured cancer,
but it's gotten a lot better,
particularly for diseases
like breast cancer, lung cancer, too.
What I'm excited about is
that this new development
that's not come from oncologists,
but from people who develop these tests,
the geneticists that can find blood,
what's called circulating DNA.
This is going
to dramatically reduce
the incidence of cancer
and certainly the death rate.
Why?
Because if you catch a
tumor when it's small,
you take some chemotherapy
and you kill it off before
it spreads and it's too late.
So that's cancer.
Heart disease.
Heart disease you can
measure through blood tests,
so we do InsideTracker,
you can see that there
are inflammatory markers
that predict cardiovascular disease.
But also, what's coming along,
that'll be added to those blood tests
is the ability to measure
your heart's function.
So I wear a device that's right here,
this one's called a BioButton,
you can see it's about an inch.
- You know you want to
take off your shirt.
- Do you want me to take off my shirt?
- I mean, I don't personally need you
to take off your shirt,
I just know that you've been
waiting for the opportunity
to take off your shirt on camera.
- That is not true, but I can show...
- He's been waiting for the opportunity,
he's shy now, but he wants to do it.
It's like Iron Man.
- We don't need to talk me taking-
- You have like a little device
right in the middle of your chest.
What is this thing?
Okay, tell me what is this
thing monitoring right now?
- Well, so instead of going
to your doctor once a year
for an annual checkup,
this thing's monitoring my
body 1,000 times a second
for vibration.
It can hear how I speak, how I cough,
it's looking at my movements,
how I sleep during the day, how I move.
But most importantly, for this device,
it's measuring my heart
in many different ways.
It's actually an FDA approved EKG,
this is something
that you have to put
stickers all over your body,
the doctor used to measure it,
sine waves and whatever,
you can now do it with your wristwatch,
though that's not FDA approved.
This one is the real deal.
Doctors use this information
to diagnose patients.
And what's it's being used for mainly now,
is to send patients home early,
who have experienced a heart attack
or have had heart surgery,
just to see if they're
doing all right at home
and hospitals save tens of
thousands of dollars that way,
for something that only costs about $20.
- But why wait for somebody
to have a heart attack,
and then send 'em home with one,
if you can put them on people
who are at risk of heart attack,
or even before then they
become at acute risk
of heart attack, right?
I mean, like if we can start
monitoring people early on,
figure out what their normal rhythm is,
be attentive when that
rhythm starts to falter,
we can catch things really, really early.
We will.
There's a future already that's here,
that this device will
send an note to my doctor
or a nurse that's scanning hundreds
and eventually millions of people.
And there'll be a red alert,
it'll be like "Minority Report",
I've seen this actually in development,
you call it up, "Here's David's heart.
"And the kidneys are
also having an issue."
The doctor then looks at it,
he probably, or she,
is playing a golf game
or doing something else,
but they can see it.
They go, "Okay, this person's
about to have a heart attack.
"Send in the robot."
This might be a molecular dynamics,
like Lex Fridman's robots.
- Okay, yeah, and I want
to talk about the future,
but I think we need to
first sort of, like,
set the stage for what's
actually going on right now,
because it's not just heart monitors.
That thing is not monitoring your blood,
but you're also wearing,
and I'm wearing also,
something that is actually
actively monitoring our blood.
- Yeah, this is the Levels
continuous glucose monitor,
it's on our arms here.
And we've been playing
with this the last week.
Together, we've been competing
to see who's got the
lower blood sugar levels.
And we just measured it
before we went on air
and we're identical.
So that's-
- You're winning, like, by a
percentage point right now.
- Right, but we're both healthy,
and what we've learned
by eating meals together
over this past episode,
is that what we eat really
makes a big difference.
So things like rice and grapes,
for me, really spike it,
potatoes, not so much.
Have you learned anything
with this device?
- I feel like I've learned
more about blood sugar
in a week of wearing this device,
than I knew about in my
entire life before then.
Now, I should say, I'm not
diabetic, I'm not prediabetic,
so really, like, under the sort
of the traditional paradigm
of how we diagnose and treat diseases,
there was no reason for me to
know what my blood sugar is.
But I'm realizing now, like, honestly,
like realizing now that,
like, there is a reason,
and the reason why is it
fundamentally changes the way
that I think about the foods
that I'm putting into my body,
because I'm now thinking
about it in context
of, "Will this do something to me
"that I know is not very good for me?"
Which is spike my blood sugar.
- Yeah, exactly.
And it's similar to
scales in your bathroom.
It's knowing that if you're told
to weigh yourself every morning,
you will lose weight more often than not.
And I liken these two to scales,
we can measure our bodies.
I mean, who's to say,
we're not allowed to
look inside our bodies.
There are doctors who don't believe
that these should be allowed
to be freely available.
- Well, in fact,
you have to have a prescription
for this right now.
- You do, you do.
And, you know, until
further studies are showing
that they're safe, you know,
that's a reasonable thing.
But I do believe that
people have the right
to look inside their bodies
and we can interpret the data.
- And shouldn't wait until
they're diseased to do so.
- Exactly.
So right now, there are some
in the medical establishment
that think that these should
only be used for diabetics.
My argument is are bathroom
scales only for those
who are morbidly obese?
No, anybody can use them to
tell more about their bodies
and how they can improve.
- Wearables have come a really long way.
So this is a blood glucose monitor.
Sort of, like, there's
a long and rich history
of blood glucose monitors,
these were sort of the first
wearables to come along,
and the first at home test
that people could use.
- Right, the history's pretty interesting.
The first ability to
measure glucose in blood
was way back, 1962.
It wasn't until 1973,
that there was a desktop or
more like a bench top analyzer,
it was more like a fridge.
- This thing was huge.
- It was massive.
But no, so 1973,
you could finally send
in a sample of blood
and have your glucose measured.
And that's how it's been done
for really up until
these devices came along.
Increasingly, we're now seeing wearables
being able to do it.
Watches, these semi-invasive needles.
Eventually what we're going to have,
is the ability to incorporate
it into one of these stickers
and not just one
measurement, but hundreds.
- And that's really where things start
to get very informative
and very interesting,
because what you can do
is now you can decide based
on your genetic profile,
your propensity for disease,
perhaps even the way
that your genes have been
methylated over time,
you can decide what the biomarkers are
that you need to know.
And you can do this in
consultation with your doctor,
another advisor
who understands these
things, you know, best.
And you can say, "Okay,
what I want to watch
"is for this and this and this."
Right now, you can look at...
Pretty much,
lots of people have access
now to blood glucose,
but we're going to be able to look
at all sorts of other blood biomarkers.
- Yeah, there's an interesting point
that it's kind of the end of
the story about my doctor.
Even though my doctor was reticent
and eventually capitulated
in giving me that prostate cancer test,
thank you, Dr. Peter.
- And you're all good?
- I'm good, yeah, right?
- Yeah.
- And it's very simple
test called the PSA test,
if you're wondering.
But what's happening
is it's not that he's a bad doctor,
it's that the medical system is not set up
to give tests willy nilly to
people that aren't yet sick.
And that has to change.
- Well, they're not covered
by most people's insurance,
unless you reach that threshold.
Again, like this whole system, right?
Like, the insurance system says,
"Yes, we will pay for it,
"but only once your diseased."
Which is as backwards.
- It is.
And there are countries
that have realized this.
So Australia provides sunblock on beaches,
they also provide free colon cancer tests,
you just poop and send it off.
Everyone in Australia gets
a free colon cancer test.
That saves billions of
dollars down the line.
Today, in the US,
pretty much you have to pay
for a lot of this yourself,
but a lot of people
realize that it's worth it.
And getting back to my doctor,
what he said was,
"Oh, you have all this
data from InsideTracker.
"Let's look at it."
So I call up on the screen all
the data and he's loving it.
So doctors, at least in
the case of my doctor,
he's not upset that I'm measuring myself.
In fact, he would do it for everybody
if the insurance would pay for it.
- Yeah, yeah.
So I also have a very old school doctor
and I love him to death,
I'm going to actually
go see him next week.
I'm really looking forward
to bringing my chart
to see him, because...
- From the Levels data?
- From the Levels data, yeah,
because I think that this is going
to inform our conversation
in a way that we've never had before.
- Well, exactly.
And it's just the beginning
of being cognizant of
that your body matters
and is changing all the time,
and there are days and months
where it's going to be way out of whack
and you wouldn't know unless
you were measuring it.
And it's all about, as we
wrote in "Lifespan", the book,
you need a dashboard for your body
in the same way you need
a dashboard for your car.
You wouldn't drive your
car without a dashboard.
Well, you could, but you
wouldn't get very far,
you'd run out of gas.
We need that for our bodies,
and it's really time that we do that.
And what we'll have is a massive reduction
in diseases like all cancers,
but colon cancer already.
We're going to have heart attacks
be a thing of the past pretty much,
'cause your doctor will
know days in advance
before you actually have a cardiac event.
And other things, even
including depression, anxiety,
these can also be measured by the devices
that we have on our bodies
or even in our hands
or the ones we type on.
These indicate diseases.
Speaking of typing,
you can tell if someone's
getting Alzheimer's
or Parkinson's just by how they type.
- Also by their movements
around the house,
there are systems that are doing that now.
Again, before we get too futuristic,
this is one of the things I really like-
- I want to get there.
- About our conversations,
You're always like, "Let's
talk about the future."
But I really want to talk about
what's available right now,
because right now, if someone wants it,
there are a variety of products
that take a variety of measurements.
There are glucose monitors
like we're wearing,
there are lactate monitors,
there are body fat, muscle mass,
body fat percentage monitors,
ECGs, caloric intake,
temperature, UV exposure,
sleep quality, blood oxygen.
Those are the things that are
just on the market right now
that you, like, just type into Google,
"I want this kind of monitor."
You can get it.
What are the, like, five biomarkers
that you would want to have?
If I just said, "You can
only have five this week.
"What are the five that you would want?"
- Well, I'm already
measuring a lot of those.
So glucose-
- But you're doing it
with InsideTracker,
which is a regular, like, what?
Monthly or bi-monthly-
- It's not constant, that's true.
- Yeah, so what would you want to be able
to monitor constantly right now?
So I would want one of these devices
to not just tell me glucose.
I want it to include heart function,
which I'm doing as well.
But I also would include inflammation.
So there's a molecule called CRP,
which I always want to keep low,
'cause that's a really good predictor
of cardiovascular disease.
- CRP is?
- C-reactive protein.
And so we've got glucose,
C-reactive protein.
Inflammation, so this would
be TNF alpha or IL one, six,
these are also predictive of longevity.
I want cortisol, keep
my stress levels down,
or also telling me if I overexercise.
- I would love to see your cortisol chart.
- I have it all, I've got
10 years of data, dude.
- Like, no, I would
love to see your, like,
minute by minute cortisol chart.
- Oh, well, yeah, hanging out
with you raises it for sure.
- And then, I think that's four.
The fifth one, let's see.
I would like to know...
Lactate would be great,
because that would tell me if my body
is able to deal with exercise adequately,
and maybe blood oxygen, too.
So when I'm exercising,
making sure that I get hypoxic,
which, as we've talked about,
is one of those adversity
mimetics that turns on your body.
Well, it is an adversity,
but it's a hormesis that doesn't kill you,
but makes your body
stronger in the long run.
- In the very near future,
we're going to have wearables
and semi-implantables,
by which I mean like things
that maybe stick a small needle
into your arm very painlessly,
like the Level sensor does.
In the sort of still
fairly near-term future,
but a little further out, nano biosensors.
- Right, and they're being developed,
I can already get those from companies.
They're not yet commercially available
and I've tried these out.
This one will measure a variety
of things through the skin,
including analytes, glucose eventually.
There are companies that
are, including Levels,
that are going to be
measuring hundreds of things,
that include the things that I mentioned.
These nanosensors they use,
they don't just use
these chemical reactions,
they'll have antibodies
that can detect proteins,
that can detect DNA, methylated DNA,
and they'll be implanted,
eventually, under the skin.
So they may last for months,
you just recharge them,
put one of those coils on the hand,
maybe for an hour, who
knows, five minutes,
you've recharged this
thing and you're good to go
and they could stay in you for life.
And we were discussing this earlier,
we had got into a bit of an
argument before we went on air
and maybe you want to hold me back,
because this is a longer discussion.
But I think that everybody
should have a biosensor in
their body at every age,
so that parents, doctors,
can monitor how people are doing
and make better decisions
about food and lifestyle.
- Well, and the thing is,
is that we are very quickly
going to be entering a world
in which there is so much data
that we're gathering by ourselves,
that it's just going to
become incomprehensible
to process by itself,
and there's going to be a lot of noise,
the signals are going to be hidden,
we're going to need AI to
help us understand this,
which means
that it's not just about
wearing the monitor 24, seven,
it's also about where the data goes.
This is the real concern
that we were having
this conversation about.
And what that means,
is that it's going to have to be
uploaded to a cloud somewhere,
to, presumably, a company.
I don't think most people
want a government doing this for them.
Although, in some countries,
we know that's probably
going to be the case.
We're starting to tread into a future
that I think a lot of people
are rightfully a little bit nervous about
or a lot nervous about.
- Well, it's going to be a company,
the government is not
developing these things,
and there are many companies
doing this, small and large.
We know Amazon and Google, Apple,
they have their health divisions.
But there are a lot of little
start-ups developing devices
that may be acquired
or may become the next healthcare giant.
It is a problem though,
that this data is massive.
There's terabytes of data
that I'm collecting on my body
and multiply that by a
billion or so people,
that's going to be a lot of data.
First of all, where do you saw it?
Who owns it?
What will be done with it?
Is it anonymized?
Is it under the HIPA act,
hopefully, in America,
that will protect it from
being used against you.
I was on a podcast with Lex Fridman
and he brought up a
really important point,
which was we have to
have these rules in place
before we start giving
all of this data away.
And he would want,
one of the main things is
that you have the right
to delete your data if you choose to.
And I don't think we're there yet,
a lot of these agreements
don't include that,
but that would be something
that we should definitely
start a conversation about.
I'm in touch with some senators
and Congress people about that.
This is a world that's coming,
it's not a question of if, it's just when,
and it's only in the next few years,
that these rules should be put in place.
- Yeah, I mean, nobody should
be waiting to talk about this,
this is an important thing
that we need to get right,
and we need to get it
right really quickly,
because the technology's not waiting
for the laws to catch up.
One of the other things
that we should mention
is, particularly when we're
talking about genetic data,
when you consent as an individual
to release your genetic data,
you're not just making a personal choice,
you're actually making
a choice for your family
who share genetic data with you,
your parents, your children,
this is not just a personal decision.
- Yeah, so every time one of
your relatives puts their DNA
and their genetic data into
a database, it affects you.
- Yeah, it's not just their information,
it's your information, too.
- Yeah, and so one of the
uses of this, obviously,
is that your family
learns about their health,
but another aspect
is that you can use it
to solve cold cases.
In the case of the Golden State Killer,
a case where there was a man, for decades,
going around murdering people,
13 murders, 50 rapes, 150 burglaries.
They finally found a
hair from this individual
that didn't have the roots,
but there wasn't much DNA,
but Ed Green and his team
at a company in Australia
that I work with,
they were able to get
enough DNA out of that hair
to track him and find a relative of him
in one of these databases.
- Using one of these public databases,
where the relative had
freely, voluntarily,
given their information.
- Right, and triangulating other aspects
that they knew about this individual.
They said, "Ah, this is the guy."
And they arrested him
and he's in jail now.
- And there's been lots
of police work like this
in recent years,
and I think a lot of people look at that
and they go, "Oh man, that's really great.
"What a great application."
The same technology used by a government
that wasn't looking for a
murderer, but a dissident,
or, you know, like a journalist,
could be really, really dangerous.
- Right, so that's why these
laws need to be looked at
and made sure that they are totally tight
so that they're cannot be a dictator
or some sort of change in government law
that can use this data
for nefarious purposes.
- The other way that our health
data affects other people
is in infectious diseases.
And so, there's another
question here about, okay,
so let's say like a
well-meaning government, right?
Identifies a contagious virus, right?
And we can track these
things now with, you know,
millions of people wearing
biomonitors everywhere.
You get a spike in one of these analytes,
and all of a sudden
whoever is tracking this,
wherever they are,
knows, "Ah, there's a virus
here, it's spreading."
And I think we're all a lot more cognizant
of, like, what this kind of looks like
and feels like in the era of COVID,
but, you know, what if it
was a disease like ebola,
not COVID, which is, by itself,
very, very dangerous and very
deadly for a lot of people,
but what if it's a virus that's
deadly for almost everyone?
- Right, there will be
big decisions to be made
by governments as to what is privacy
and what is collectively good.
And we've seen that over this
relatively minor pandemic,
the big one is going to come
in our lifetimes, probably,
as we wrote about in "Lifespan".
I'm on the front lines of this as well.
I was building a company,
have a company called Arc Bio,
that is able to detect viruses
and fungi and bacteria in human blood,
and any sample, from a spit sample,
in the effort to get ahead of COVID-19.
Now, it came a little too
early, we weren't ready,
but there are patients now
that are being monitored
by Arc Bio's technology with a blood test,
that sees everything in the body.
And instead of pulling out
the human DNA from a hair,
what we do is we pull out the human DNA
and see what's left behind.
And those are the pathogens,
and we can actually diagnose
an infectious disease
without even knowing what to look for.
- There's a lot of implications here
that once again, like, you know,
we should be talking about
now, rather than waiting.
If people are going to be engaged
in anything about the internet of things
or what some people are
calling the internet of body,
this is the thing that we
should really be focused on
and talking about.
Because it's not just voluntary
patches that we're wearing,
we're figuring out lots of different ways
to collect this information,
it's going to get easier and easier,
and a lot of people are going to do this,
because it looks convenient.
- Yeah, well, let's go
through some of the sensors
that are here now
and ones that are just
about to come on the market.
Look at me, I'm wearing
the blood glucose monitor,
which we've talked about, we love.
I've got a ring that measures my sleep
and my heart rate and my movement.
Really need to focus on sleep.
This helps me, it makes
me cognizant of my sleep.
I've got one of these
watches that does heart,
it does movement, walking, exercise.
So I'm already a bit of a cybernaut-
- And you've got that one on your chest.
- Well, don't forget, yeah,
this one's not commercially
available, but will be soon.
- Right, and you're doing the
InsideTracker blood draws,
- Right.
So I know a lot about my body
and I've actually been getting healthier
and fitter over the years
because of it, it's no accident,
and I love what I'm able to do.
I'm a scientist and I can correct things
when they're out of whack and not optimal,
and I wouldn't be able to do
that if I didn't monitor it.
But I'm excited about the other things
I'll be able to monitor
right now I'm blind to.
Speaking of which, contact lenses.
Contact lenses are one area
you can measure blood glucose levels.
There are tooth sensors,
you can measure bacteria in your mouth.
You can also, currently, through
Viome and other companies,
I was talking
to the CEO of Viome the
other day, Naveen Jain,
he's got a colon cancer test
that works better than
anything on the market,
but he also can see health
and give you supplements that
will improve your health,
based on what's in your gut,
and that's going to be monitored as well.
I'm not sure how, maybe in the toilet.
- That's a poop test?
- Right now, you send off your poop,
but eventually there'll be a
device in your home, I imagine.
- Which is literally something
people are doing right now,
is they're sending their poop by mail to-
- I've done it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it felt weird going to the store
with a box full of my poop,
but I did it in the case
of a colon cancer test,
which a lot of Australians
are doing just normally.
But it is weird.
- We should probably say,
it's not a whole poop.
Wait, did you send a whole poop?
- Well, what do you think it is?
- It's just a swab.
- I think it's a fairly
large piece of poop in a jar.
- Wow.
Okay, so this is the
reality that we live in now.
- It was a big bottle,
and then you put in liquid
and you shake, it's gross.
But I learnt that I
didn't have colon cancer,
so that was worth it.
- It's probably worth it, right.
And I think a of these...
I mean, sort of like the
overarching theme here,
is that a lot of these
things come with trade offs.
They come with the trade off
for the potential for embarrassment,
there are privacy implications.
We have to measure those trade offs
against what we potentially can gain.
Some of these other biosensors
are put into mouth guards.
- For lactate?
Or is it uric acid?
- The mouth guard biosensors,
I'm not sure what they're using.
Although, I have heard them implicated
in, like, youth athletics,
because when you have a concussion,
you immediately start to
see markers in the blood.
And so, presumably in the saliva too,
those can test those.
There's temporary tattoo biosensors,
and there's also sweat
microfluidic biosensors
that can detect all kinds of hormones.
- Right, and then eventually,
we'll have these optimized
athletes as well.
Already they're wearing a lot of devices,
but eventually they'll be
monitored for all sorts of things,
like a Formula one racing car.
- Well, but what you're suggesting though,
is that eventually everyone will,
from pretty much every
age, be being monitored,
you said thousands of times each second.
- Doesn't it make sense?
It makes sense to me.
I wouldn't want to walk around,
potentially going to have
a heart attack tomorrow
or having cancer grow on
me and not know about it.
I want to know this stuff.
And that's what I think
will lengthen our lives
by another decade,
beyond what we're able to do
with changes to lifestyle.
- Let's bring this
together with aging though,
because so far,
what we've really been talking about
is the transitions that we
can see in our biochemistry
that take us from states of
wellness to states of disease,
that's really important.
How aging fits into
this is also important.
- Well, there are a number of ways
to measure your biological age.
I've used InsideTracker
for over a decade now
to steadily get ostensibly
younger biochemically,
over that decade.
I was 48 and it spiked, my age went up,
based on their inner age test.
And then I changed my lifestyle,
I started taking NMN, Metformin,
and got that number, inner age,
down to 31.4 in a matter of months.
That doesn't mean I
was literally that age,
just means that my blood
biochemistry markers
matched somebody that was more like 34.
- Right now, in order to have
your biological aging assessed
through one of these methylation clocks,
it's pretty expensive,
it's really time consuming,
it can take weeks, if not
months, to get results back.
You're involved in an effort
to try to bring down both the price point
and the time period
that people have to wait to
learn their biological age.
- Yeah, these tests
aren't perfect right now,
they're fairly expensive,
they take weeks to get results.
But that's going to change.
The student in my lab,
you know Patrick Griffin,
he spent his PhD trying to
figure out how to make it cheap.
And he figured it out,
we've just put a paper online.
Viewers can go and download that,
it's at a site called bioRxiv,
Sinclair, Griffin,
keyword TIME-Seq, S-E-Q.
That paper is describing a way
to do this methylation
clock for 1,000 times less.
We're spinning out a company,
we're in the process of
hopefully in the next few months,
having a product available.
So people can at home do a cheek swab
and routinely measure
their biological age,
which is important,
because there are ways to
slow down and stop aging,
soon, reverse aging,
and without that test,
you won't know what's working for you.
People can sign up, we
haven't got the product yet,
but there is a website,
it's doctorsinclair.com,
spell out the word doctor,
doctorsinclair.com,
and you can get on a wait list.
Do that, because the more people we have,
the more experiments we can do together
to figure out what slows
aging and even reverses it.
- Once you have that number
and bringing that together
with all of these other metrics
that we've been talking about,
the measurements of the microbiome,
the measurements of the blood analytes,
all of the stuff that you're getting
from, like, your smartwatch
or whatever sensors you're wearing,
you can start making decisions
in your day to day life.
Let's talk about some of those.
What does this look like
in terms of the way that
we eat in the future?
'Cause what we've already said
is you've got to eat better,
but this is eating better and
eating more informed as well.
- Yeah, well there are
a couple of companies
that we're involved with,
and they support this show,
that tell us what we can eat.
So Levels is telling us what's bad to eat
for raising blood sugar
and what we should avoid.
The app, actually, we were
looking at this together,
you can compare foods with
this app, which is fun.
InsideTracker also provides
nutritional recommendations,
you might want to...
If you're deficient in vitamin D,
they send you off and you
should eat more salmon,
they even have recipes.
Suffice it to say that
we're entering a world
where you'll be able
to look at your phone,
it'll tell you what things
to buy at the shop, at the supermarket,
and even what local
restaurants you can go to
and which meals you should
have to optimize your health.
- Once we have all these measurements,
you can watch your biological
clock from week to week,
you can watch your blood analytes go up
and down within the
course of a single day.
- Your heart.
- You can watch your heart rate,
you can watch all of these things.
Once you have those things,
you can start making decisions
about the way that you eat,
which is really one of the biggest ways
that we can impact these.
- Well, that's what I do.
It's not just that you can, you should.
And the sort of decisions
that you can make
are, okay, if you're
deficient in vitamin D,
you can be directed towards
eating certain foods, like fish,
that have vitamin D.
Or if you have certain
high levels of cortisol,
reduce your stress, do meditation,
don't exercise so hard.
These are tweaks to your life
that otherwise you wouldn't
know that you needed to do.
- And the apps that will sort of, like,
help you along in this regimen,
you're not going to be expected
to know all of this stuff yourself,
they're going to lead
you through the process.
- Well, they do.
Most of these apps are
taking a lot of data,
it's often terabytes of data,
and distilling it down
into a few simple steps
for you to do each day.
- Even if you're doing everything right,
you're eating the right way,
there's still times
that these measurements
are going to tell you, "Hey, actually,
"you're missing out on this."
And so now, we're getting
into this conversation about,
like, perhaps supplementation as well.
- Yeah, that's a key component.
It's particularly important
for people who are on specialized diets,
say, if you're a vegan or a vegetarian,
you're going to be lacking
in vitamin B12, probably,
you may have low NAD levels,
because you're getting older,
you measure those,
and then you'll have
recommendations to supplement
and bring those levels
back to an optimal level.
They'll probably recommend,
"Go get that brand."
Or, "Go get that."
Right now, it's very difficult,
you don't know what brands to choose,
I'm working on a way
to solve that as well.
But ultimately, I think what's
going to happen is in our homes,
we're going to have a machine
that can give us a poly pill
with the minerals, the vitamins,
maybe even the medicines that
we need, right on the spot.
- Feels like a little compounding pharmacy
right on your kitchen encounter.
- And this isn't crazy stuff.
Daniel Kraft, an MD,
a good friend of mine
from Stanford University,
has a company
that's built a machine
that's not yet available,
that does mix those minerals,
vitamins, and even medicines,
right there on your kitchen
countertop every morning.
- And the thing about this,
is that what we're talking
about then are, you know,
pills that are created
specifically for a specific person,
as opposed to what we get right
now when we go to the store,
which is a capsule that is the size
that some average person
needs, whatever that means.
- Right, it's not even male
and female half the time,
but even if it is,
it's, "Oh, men take
this, women take that."
Not even asking how much volume
or how much does that person weigh.
We can be, you know, some people,
three times heavier than others.
- Right, on the side of,
like, the Tylenol bottle,
it says like adults and children.
Like, there's nothing else to consider-
- It's ridiculous.
- Right?
- Right, but these pills
that are made in the home,
they're going to be made
specially for you, for that day,
for that time of day and
for what you've been eating.
- And for your genome, too.
- Exactly.
- Right?
Because people have different DNA,
process and metabolize different chemicals
in different ways.
Once that's worked into this,
we can really, really start to pinpoint
what people actually need,
as opposed to what most
people need most of the time.
- Right.
And actually, medicine
as it's currently called,
is based on an average person.
And so, those ranges that doctors look at
to say, "Oh, you're sick.
Or, "You're not."
Are based on an average human
and doesn't take into
account often your history,
your genetics, what you've been eating,
how biologically old you are.
And these things should be
brought to bear as well.
And eventually, doctors
will have this information
and all be assisted by AI.
But right now, we're in
that transition zone.
And interestingly, the AI
is being used by customers,
not by doctors so much.
- These tracking devices
and the measurements that they give us,
are also going to help us understand
how to exercise more effectively
in a way that will help us
not just bring down
these individual levels,
but also presumably bring down
our biological age over time.
- Already, we can do that.
The ring that I'm wearing,
the wristband, this patch,
they're measuring my
heart rate constantly.
They're looking at heart rate variability,
which you want to be high.
They're also looking
at resting heart rate,
which you want to be low in general.
There are certain ways to improve that,
there's running, there's weights,
there's yoga, even meditation.
The apps will soon be so sophisticated,
they'll say, "Okay, today you
should go on this run here.
"I'll send you on a map.
"This'll be nice.
"It's good weather."
Versus, "Oh, maybe today you need a rest.
"You've got a bit of cortisol.
"You ran yesterday, do
some weights today."
And that is going to be
optimized, in addition,
with the supplements.
They're going to say, "Okay,
don't take this supplement today,
"because I'm going to tell
you to go lift weights."
- I imagine this world where, like,
Siri becomes your personal trainer.
- Pretty much you're going to
have a guardian angel for health,
and when that happens,
you're going to look at the days
when we went for an annual physical
as though those days are medieval.
- There's not going to be a
one size fits all solution
for everybody when it comes to exercise,
just like diet and supplementation, right?
Everybody's going to be different.
- Well clearly, and I
say this all the time,
when I give talks, people ask me,
"Well, what should I do?
"Tell me what you do,
David, and I'll do that."
Well, that's what people should do,
because everybody's different,
genetically, physically, even mentally.
What I can do, skip meals,
some people cannot do.
So even though on, as
I often say, page 304,
I listed what I do in the book,
that's not the perfect prescription
for everybody, of course,
because everyone's different.
So you've got to measure
yourself like I do
and see what works for
you and what doesn't.
- Before we get off the
subject of exercise,
I wanted to talk a little bit
about this idea of exercise mimetics.
Right now we know,
particularly in animal studies,
the mice in your lab
are getting an exercise benefit
out of consumption of NMN.
But NMN is a pretty rudimentary molecule,
it's not a designer, it's pretty simple.
There are new drugs coming down the line,
as we're talking about the future,
is there a point in
time in which, you know,
these supplements, these drugs,
are going to allow us
to be our slovenly selves
without consequence?
- Well, we're not there yet.
And in fact, what the
data says from my lab,
is that when you give
NMN and you exercise,
you get the best benefit.
So it's not an excuse to sit
around and just pop a pill,
but there is a need for better medicines.
The reason that I'm developing,
at one of my companies,
a better NMN version,
is that the elderly
and people who just came
in with a heart attack
or have kidney failure,
they cannot be on a fasting regimen easily
or asked to go for a run.
So you do need to be able to deliver these
with a pill or with IV.
But for those of us who are still fit,
the best bang for the buck,
at least with today's technology,
is to eat right, move right,
and supplement in a way that
you can see by monitoring,
what's optimizing your body for longevity.
- Ultimately, one of the places
that you think we may wind up,
is a world in which we can reset the clock
through a course of treatments.
And you've done experiments
about this in your lab,
you've had quite a bit of success
with mice in doing this,
and this is what the Fahy
trials seem to be showing
in Southern California.
Let's dive into that,
because this is not immediate,
but it is likely down the road somewhere
in the fairly near future.
- Well, so Greg Fahy,
the professor out in California
who's doing this with patients
and published with Steve Horvath,
they're seeing a couple
of years retreat in age
in 12 months of treatment,
with a combination of three factors
that we discussed in an earlier episode.
But this is just the beginning,
this is the early days of flight,
we're just learning how this works,
but very rapidly over the next few years,
we're going to learn what else
can reverse the age of the body,
certainly the blood clock,
which is what's being used right now.
And there are reports
of people going back 10,
even 20 years with certain treatments.
So this is a golden
age for aging research.
I didn't realize when I
started out in my career,
I didn't expect to be
talking about age reversal,
I thought, "Oh yeah, we'll,
we'll slow down aging
"and that'll be the best, if we're lucky."
We're in a world, that for me,
is science fiction already,
we're way beyond my expectations,
which is super exciting.
- The other thing that you're working on,
and I think a lot of people
are really excited about,
is this idea of an epigenetic
reset of biological age.
This is stuff that you're
doing in your lab right now.
Let's talk about taking mice
and reversing their biological age.
- Right.
So we're talking about a gene therapy.
We found that there are three genes
that are normally turned on in
embryos that keep them young,
that we could turn on
again in the adult animal
and in human cells.
So it works in both species.
But in the mice,
we could manipulate
them to see what happens
when you rejuvenate their
tissues using these three genes.
What we-
- And the genes are?
- Well, the they're called oct
four, SOCS two and KLF four.
These are what are called
transcription factors,
proteins that bind to DNA
and turn on genetic programs.
- And they're part of the series of genes
that people call the Yamanaka factors.
- Yes.
So Shinya Yamanaka from Japan,
won the Nobel Prize in 2016 for
the discovery of five genes,
three of which I've just
mentioned, there are two others,
that were able to take
cells, an adult cell,
back to a pluripotent stem cell stage,
like basically age zero.
And then, you could...
We do use these cells
to build other tissues,
they can be turned into
nerve cells and muscle.
But you don't want to do that in the body,
you'll become the world's largest tumor.
So we found that a combination
of three of these genes
and leaving out the
other two dangerous ones,
was a perfect way to
reset the age of the body,
without causing cancer.
And it worked better than
we could even predict it.
We put these genes, using a virus,
into the eye, for example,
we could do the whole body as well,
but let's focus on the eye.
- You did into the eye of a mouse.
- It's a mouse-
- Yeah.
- We hope in a couple of years,
we'll be testing our first human,
and right now, we've done mice,
we're now doing non-human primates.
So we're getting closer.
But in the mice, it was
just a stunning result,
which is a mouse that's
had its optic nerve damaged
or a mouse that has glaucoma,
which is pressure in the
eye that causes blindness,
it affects millions of
people around the world,
or just old age,
these mice were essentially blind.
We then put the virus in
with these three genes,
could turn on those three
genes, O, S and K for short,
and four weeks later, those
cells, the retinal cells,
the nerve cells that go to
the brain, went back in time,
they became young again, reset their age,
according to the Horvath clock.
Their gene expression patterns,
which means the genes
that were dysregulated,
went back to being regulated
perfectly for a nerve cell,
and the mice got their vision back.
We actually cured blindness in those mice,
which was a stunning result.
We also showed that the
systems that reset the clock,
there are enzymes that control
DNA methylation called TEDS.
Without those, we didn't
get vision restoration,
and the clock didn't go back.
So what that tells us
is the clock going backwards is doable.
there is a reset switch in the body,
and that the clock is part of that system.
- And this all sounds...
I know, to people who
haven't heard about it,
at first it sounds sort
of futuristic and crazy,
this was the cover story
on the journal, Nature.
- Yeah, December, 2020,
we were fortunate enough
to get the cover's issue,
it's a dream for any scientist.
And the title that they had on the cover
was "Turning Back Time"
and a picture of an eyeball
with a clock hand going.
Yeah, that was one of the
highlights of my career,
and what's happened since
is there's been a whirlwind
of interest in this from
scientists around the world.
Investors, there's more
than 20 billion with a B,
$20 billion being raised
to look at this actual
phenomenon of aging reset,
and a lot of scientists
are turning their attention
towards understanding how this works,
and even mimicking this gene
therapy with little molecules,
perhaps plant molecules
or drugs that are on the market already,
so that one day, hopefully
in the next five to 10 years,
we could take a pill or
rub a cream on our skin,
not just to slow aging,
but to truly reset the age of the body.
- Between then and now,
there's obviously a lot of work to do.
We've seen this effect
in the eyes of mice,
you're working on other
systems within a mouse as well.
- Well, we are, and in
humans, I should say,
we're trying to go as quickly as we can.
We've found that the reset
works in other parts of the eye,
we can restore vision in mice
that have what's called
retinal degeneration
or macular degeneration.
We also have skin reversal
for humans and mice,
and we've even built little mini brains,
we grow these little
organoids out of human skin,
we give them Alzheimer's disease,
these little brains get dementia,
and we can reset the
age of those mini brains
and they get their
electrical activity back.
So this is the beginnings of work
that I hope will mean
that we can reverse the age of
the brain and other tissues,
and diseases of old age,
like Alzheimer's, heart disease,
even cancer, will go away.
- What this would look like
in practice, presumably,
at some time in the future,
would be a course of treatment, right?
Like, you have experienced
some degree of aging,
you decide, "Hey, it's time
for me to take care of this."
You go in, you have this gene therapy,
and then these genes
are basically turned on
inside your body to do their work.
- That's right.
And we built the system and the virus,
so we could turn it on with
an antibiotic, doxycyclin.
And the patients that we
treat, if we treat them,
will take a course of antibiotics
to turn on the reprogramming.
So we can turn it on for,
say, four to eight weeks.
We can measure their vision.
When they get their vision back again,
they stop the antibiotics.
Then, they age out again,
maybe another decade,
and then all they get in the mail
is another course of antibiotics
to restore their vision again.
- A lot of people
are going to be really
concerned by this idea
of, like, gene therapy,
but there are, as you noted, like,
some other avenues that we
might get a very similar result.
Greg Fahy's work is
aimed at this same idea
of an epigenetic reprogramming
without the genetic therapy.
He's doing this through some
pretty simple chemicals.
- Yeah, so he's in California
and he used three treatments.
It's called the TRIIM Trial
and it included Metformin,
growth hormone and DHEA, another hormone.
And so, growth hormone
will rebuild tissues,
and that gives a response in
the body that times are good,
but he also counteracted
that with adversity mimetics,
the Metformin and the DHEA
prevented glucose spikes
and type-two diabetes.
And what he showed after
a year of this treatment
was that the epigenetic
clock measured by Horvath,
remember, this is the
DNA methylation patterns,
reset in a way that was calculated
to take their blood biomarkers back,
their blood clock back two
and a half years on average.
Now, that doesn't seem like a lot.
- That was after one year of treatment.
One year of treatment on this
course of these three drugs,
bought two and a half years
in equivalent biological age?
- Yeah, and at first I said,
"Two and a half years,
come on, that's not much."
But then I realized if
you do that every year
or even every two years, you're immortal,
and that's when things
get really interesting.
But what we don't know
is are these treatments just
changing the blood clock
or are they changing the whole body?
So we need to measure other things,
including skin clocks
and blood biomarkers,
to really know if this
is a true aging reset.
- So there's a bunch of ways
that we're trying to
approach the same goal,
which is this, like,
repeatable resetting of age.
As of right now,
we don't know how many
times it's repeatable,
whether you can do it
once or twice or 10 times
or however many times we want?
- We don't know, but I
was speaking with Greg,
who's a friend of mine,
he said that he's been
repeating this treatment.
And, you know, often when
these publications come out,
we scientists know a lot more
than we're telling people.
And what he told me,
which I'll share with
all the audience today
is it works multiple times.
So he's now getting
people to go back five,
and there are some reports
of people going back 10 years
in their blood's biological age.
- What do we need to know,
to know whether that's
safe in the long-term?
And what do we need to
know to know whether or not
that can be continued in the long-term?
There's not some drop off at some point,
where it, like, just is
not going to work anymore.
- Yeah, we don't know,
this is new territory,
and I think that's a
really important point,
is we don't know the dangers
of resetting the age.
We believe that it's safe.
So far, there's been no
indication of any downside.
But one of the big worries is
if you go back too far in age,
you can stimulate cancer cells.
So that's another thing to watch out for.
But I'm an optimist.
I'm optimistic that if
the body becomes younger,
it'll surveil the body
and kill the cancer cells,
which is one of the
problems as we get older
and why tumors develop,
is that our body's immune system
doesn't kill those cancer cells.
But, you know, obviously we
have a lot of work to do,
we're not saying go out
and try gene therapy today.
We could do that theoretically,
but definitely don't,
we don't know all the risks,
and particularly with gene
therapy, it can be irreversible.
So this is something...
- Yeah, once you do it-
- Don't try this at home.
- You're committed.
- Right, and there can be
other side effects as well,
from gene therapy,
including immune responses
to those viruses.
One word about those viruses
is that it's still early
days on gene delivery.
One of the reasons we haven't
immediately had success
with extending the lifespan of mice,
is that those viruses are very hard
to distribute evenly through the body.
Even in even humans,
it's a struggle for diseases
that want to be treated holistically.
But there are advances,
there're a number of new
companies that have sprung up
that allow these viruses to
infect the body more evenly.
And when that happens,
I think we will be able to make mice
that can live a decade or two.
- So if we could take a mouse
that right now has a
lifespan of about two years,
and we can make it live a decade or two,
and just playing
with this idea of optimism
for a moment here,
and sort of, like,
setting aside all of
the things that, like,
we don't know yet,
those kinds of impacts on a human life,
puts us out well past the 100 year marker,
well past the 120 year marker.
We start getting into territory
that a lot of people
just have a really hard
time even fathoming.
But again, just playing
with that for a moment here,
what we're talking about in the long-term,
is a world where people
are living these incredibly longer lives,
presumably hopefully healthier as well.
A lot of people,
the first thing that they
hear when they hear that
is more people on an already
really crowded planet.
You hear this a lot from people.
- Well, I do,
even when we talk about
extending lifespan by five years,
people wonder what are we going
to do with all these people?
And the good news is, if
you do the calculations,
first of all, most advanced countries,
economically advanced,
the rates of population growth
are starting to decline,
even here in the US, it's coming down-
- 'Cause people are having fewer children
over the last few generations
as these countries get richer.
- Yeah, richer leads to fewer offspring.
Wealth, health, these all lead
to people making decisions that,
"I don't need to have 3, 5, 10 kids."
And this is increasingly happening
in South America and in Africa as well.
And the prediction is that humanity
will peak at about 10 billion, maybe 11,
and start to come down again,
and that's going to be when these changes
actually happen to humanity,
that people will live longer
and there will not be an excess of people,
it's not that we'll be overcrowded,
that's clear from the math.
The other concern people have
is what about all the resources?
And clearly, we need to figure out ways
to preserve the planet,
preserve the environment,
and not destroy it with
our over consumption.
And one of the solutions that
often people don't think about
is that these changes to human biology
will allow people to
be much more productive
and less costly to the economy.
Right now, we throw away 17%
of our GDP in the US on healthcare.
Well, we don't throw it away,
but a lot of that is used in
the last few years of life,
which we can probably
fix with this technology.
We've calculated that if
we could extend lifespan
by just one year, using
Metformin as an example,
which probably could
work better than that,
the value to the US economy in
the long run is $86 trillion.
And if you do it for 10
years, it's 365 trillion,
we just published this in
the journal, Nature Aging.
That is money that can be
put towards other problems,
improving education,
helping to combat climate
change, among other things,
making the world much more
efficient and less wasteful.
- We've get to use that
money wisely, though.
I mean, like, there was this sense
at the end of the cold war
that we were going to
have this peace dividend,
and all this money that
we were spending on war,
we were now going to be able to spend
on all these social programs
and making people's lives better,
and we just threw it
back into the military.
There's also a possibility
that we misuse this.
So this is another instance
where we really need to start
having these conversations now
and really working them
into the conversations
and making sure that policy
makers understand the world
that we're potentially entering into.
- For sure.
But the sums are astronomical.
Already, we've got more money
being put into reprogramming
and age correction,
epigenetic reprogramming,
than ever in any other
time in medical history.
This is a true historical event
that we're experiencing here.
It's one of the reasons we
wanted to do this podcast
is to bring people along as
these amazing changes happen.
But also, the sums of
money that we'll be saving
are also unprecedented.
$360 trillion just in the US,
that's money that, yeah,
even if some is wasted,
there's going to be a lot
to use for good purposes.
But I think what we want to
do is educate Congress people,
that when this money comes,
it's used for the right purposes.
- And that's on the healthcare
saving side of things,
which tends to be the later
in life side of things.
There's another advantage to this too,
is that if we can
lengthen lifespans, right?
The portion of a human life
that we spend educating someone right now
is about a quarter of their life, right?
It's the first 20 years of
their life, give or take.
And then you get, you know, two decades,
or two equivalent time periods
where they work, right?
So you get about a 40 year career,
and then you get a 20 year period
at the end of their
life where they're sick.
But if you can extend out that time
in which they are being productive,
all of a sudden all of
those educational costs
become even better investments.
And they already are,
and as you and I both agree I know,
education is the best investment
we can make in our society.
- Right, and not everybody starts out life
with a career that they want.
They don't have the opportunity,
and so with a longer life,
there should be multiple
opportunities to change careers
and do things that people
have always wanted to do.
But to make that possible,
we advocate a skill-batical,
a term that we coined.
This would be two or
three years paid time off
to change careers,
to do something you always wanted.
Everyone should have that opportunity.
- Throughout the course of people's lives.
- Yeah, as lives get longer and
more productive and healthy,
there should be multiple
opportunities to change
and do, ultimately, what people
have always wanted to do.
My father is a good example, he's now 82.
He left his main career
in his late 60s, 67,
and he thought he was going
to die in 10 years from then
and it wasn't going to be very pretty.
He's now 82, he's as
healthy as he ever was.
He's stronger than me.
He started a new career in his 70s.
This is the kind of life
that I want for everybody,
that we don't have to
worry about getting cancer
in our 50s and 60s or having
a heart attack in our 70s.
We should be able to live in our 80s,
90s and beyond in a healthy way,
contributing to society,
educating the community,
educating our kids, our grandkids,
even our great grandkids
with all the wisdom
that we accumulate over our lifetimes.
It's a huge waste when
somebody 80, 90 or 100 dies.
- Well, it's such a waste that,
we've argued about this before,
you've suggested that people
don't just have a right to live that long,
they really have a responsibility
and an obligation to live that long-
- Well, they do-
- And healthy.
- Well, it's important.
Most people who are
over the age of 40 or 50
have taken care of a
grandparent or a parent,
who's gotten sick.
It's a huge burden on everybody,
and it's not just bad for
the person who's dying,
it's bad for the family,
it's costly, time consuming,
and emotionally draining to say the least.
What we're talking about
is take responsibility for yourself,
but also do it for your kids
and your grandkids sake,
because if you live a long time
and are not a burden on your family
and you live a long time,
you'll probably die much
quicker, that's the statistic,
your kids'll thank you for it.
And I think we have a right
and an obligation to do that.
- Most people, I think,
when you present to them the opportunity
to live longer and healthier,
they say, "Oh yeah, I
would like that future."
Right now, the things
that we have talked about
that make that kind of a future easier,
reprogramming, really, really effective,
drugs and supplements,
they're getting there,
but they're not there.
Which means if somebody wants
to partake in this future
and they're of any age right now,
they actually have to put in the work.
It's not just going to be handed to them
in the next few years.
- No, it's not just
simple as take two pills
and call me in the morning kind of stuff
or call me in the next
decade, it is hard work.
You don't get anything for free.
You can't just yet pop a pill
and go back 20, 30 years,
though maybe in the future we will.
But for now, the best
recipe for long life,
greater health and ensure
that you make it past 80, 90,
maybe even into your 100s,
is to do the right things.
There's eat the right way, okay?
Eat the right of kind of diets.
Don't eat as often, have
some period of fasting.
Get some type of exercise.
Even better, do multiple
different types of exercise.
Stress your body out a little
bit, give it some hormesis,
these are adversity mimetics,
so a bit of cold, a bit of
heat, those kind of things.
The other thing we talked
about is some supplements
and these new technologies
we've talked about today,
the monitoring and other things,
that will actually
allow us to live longer.
And you might say, "Well, do
I care about living longer?"
Well, absolutely, you should.
Why?
Because the longer you live,
the longer you will live.
Right now, if we live an extra year,
we get another three months of life,
'cause these technologies
are going so fast.
And soon, we'll have
another six months of life
every year we live,
and eventually another year
for every year we live.
And that's when things
get super interesting.
- David, in this series so
far, we've covered a lot.
I know a lot of it was dense.
Some of it, we probably
moved too fast for people on.
Some of it, we didn't move fast enough on.
Some of it, people might
want to review again.
If they do want that,
the good news is the show notes
are going to be available.
They're going to be timestamped,
so you can go right to the topics
that you want to learn more about.
Those are thanks to our really
amazing team of researchers.
- Yeah, we've been really lucky,
we've got a great team
here that we want to
thank, you and I.
One is the researchers.
So a lot of the facts here
that have come out of the
scientific literature,
were brought to our us by
Sarah Ryan and Adiv Johnson.
They've been awesome.
Thanks, guys.
We also want to thank our producer.
We've got Rob Mohr
and his assistant producer, Jack Jameson.
- Yeah.
If there's anything
that people want us to dive
deeper on in the future,
presuming a future of
another season of this,
they can leave notes
wherever they're watching their podcast.
- Yeah, hopefully we'll
have a great reception.
People can leave five
stars on Apple Podcasts
and tell us if they like it-
- You know, just as a
suggestion, five stars.
- Yeah, that would be fine.
But seriously, we're paying attention,
whether we should do
another series or not,
and we'll decide based on the reaction.
Hopefully, people love what we do.
They want a deeper dive.
They want to know more about fertility,
even sexual performance,
we could jump into.
- You really want to do that episode.
We can do it, like,
I'm excited about that episode too.
I think there is a ton to
be said about aging and sex.
There's a ton to be said
about aging and society.
There's so many more
topics that we can hit.
- And there are a lot that we
haven't thought of, I'm sure,
and our viewers can tell us
what they want to hear about.
So we'll pay attention to the suggestions.
And if there are enough
people interested in a topic,
we'll dive into the scientific literature
that's inaccessible to most people,
and bring those in a factual way,
and hopefully in a way that is digestible
and easy to understand,
but also entertaining.
Most importantly, what we want to do here,
and hopefully we've done this
in the last eight episodes here,
is to give people an
idea of what's possible.
That their long-term longevity
and their daily wellness and performance
is truly in their own hands,
even with today's
knowledge and technology.
And just around the corner,
we're going to have things
that we can barely dream of.
- And wherever we go next,
now people who've listened to this,
hopefully have a really
baseline understanding
of the fundamental nature
of where the research is,
where it's coming from,
where aging comes from and
what we can do about it,
which means that whatever
we cover in the future,
we can start from that
place and build from there.
- Exactly.
We can do some deep dives
into various topics.
It can be about blood
glucose and monitoring.
It could be about fertility in women.
We've got lots to cover,
if we do another set of eight episodes,
which we hope we'll do.
And depending on the feedback from people,
if it's really positive,
and we hope that it will be,
we'll do another eight, I think.
You want to come back and do one?
- Yeah, I do.
- Another series?
- Although, I think there's some debate
about where the location is going to be.
We're filming in Boston right now.
- And you want to go to
your place, probably?
- I think a combinatory
podcast series recording,
slash ski vacation sounds really good.
- Yeah, Mr. Park City, Utah.
Okay, sounds good to me.
We'll have to ask our boy
wonder, Rob, the producer,
but I would love to do that.
Thanks so much for joining us
in this first season of
the Lifespan podcast.
Again, please let us know your thoughts
and questions in the
comment section on YouTube
and on social media,
and let us know if we
should do a season two.
If you'd like to support us,
please share this episode and others
with those you think might
benefit from the information.
To stay informed of future episodes,
subscribe on YouTube,
Apple Podcasts and Spotify.
And on Apple, you have the opportunity
to leave up to a five star review.
Also, please check out the sponsors
that we mentioned at the
start of the episode,
that's probably the best
way to support the show.
We also have a Patreon account.
It's at patreon.com/davidsinclair.
There, you can support
us at any level you like.
Thanks again for joining us.
It's been a lot of fun and
our hope through this series,
we've shown that aging
is not just something to
focus on late in life,
but something you should focus on daily,
to feel better each day and
be healthier for longer.
Maybe we'll see you next time.